[Musique]
je suis heureux de faire une promesse de
don de 2 milliards de dollars alloués à
la restauration de la nature et la
transformation du système alimentaire
400 jet privé ont atterri à glasgow pour
le sommet pour le climat tellement
d'avions privés et bien qu'un
gigantesque embouteillage s'est créé joe
biden qui lui a débarqué en écosse avec
une escorte d'une vingtaine de voitures
dont the beast la cadillac blindée du
président qui pèse près de 8 tonnes et
consomme dix fois plus qu'une voiture
normale à portland aux états unis le
top-6 public d'un corps humain organisée
dans un grand hôtel a fait polémique 70
spectateurs ont déboursé 500 $ chacun
fonds bat des records de de feu de deux
tempêtes d'inondation et ça ça se voit
très très clairement et sage et très
clairement vu la différence par rapport
à la 1ère émission ya quatre ou cinq ans
le problème c'est que la famille du
défunt n'avait pas connaissance que le
corps subirait ce genre d'exhibition
payante finalement le meilleur bilan
carbone à celui du président chinois bah
oui qu'il n'est pas venu à la coop 93%
soit la quasi totalité des français se
disent préoccupés par la sécurité la
première fois que j'ai fait du
porte-à-porte je suis tombé sur une dame
nue elle était allongée dans le salon le
monsieur qui m'a ouvert m'a proposé de
prendre un café mais j'ai dit non vous
le confie yuma dit rires dans
l'assistance tout le monde était séduit
86 % des sympathisants de gauche sont
préoccupés par la sécurité ce qui
signifie que maintenant c'est plus un
tabou même à gauche est âgé de 68 ans il
est interpellé mercredi le chanteur est
soupçonné d'avoir eu des relations
sexuelles avec deux adolescentes entre
2013 et 2014 les journalistes me
détestent non pas personnellement je
pense mais idéologiquement et ils
veulent absolument me faire rendre gorge
politique et ils sont prêts à tout
tous les soirs il y à des documentaires
sur moi à charge évidemment est qui qui
sortent sur toutes les chaînes et c'est
bon tout le temps les journaux vous avez
raison le monde fait des articles pour
me dire à quel point je suis à danger
pour la démocratie
jean luc lahaye sa fille ne sont pas les
seuls en garde à vue les deux mères des
jeunes filles le sont également pour non
dénonciation de crime et complicité de
viol sur mineur de plus de 15 ans elle
aurait poussé leurs enfants à avoir des
relations avec le chanteur avant de leur
demander de se taire et il va y avoir
des divisions probablement assez
profonde sheller parce que les batailles
de primaires ça laisse des traces on l'a
vu c'est assez destructeur je mettrai
fin au système actuel de régularisation
je proposerai également de diviser par
deux le nombre de visas étudiants
accordée annuellement je proposerai au
parlement de diviser par 3 l'immigration
familiale la france voulait marquer le
coup voilà c'était hier soir abondent
pour sa dernière visite officielle en
france je voulais te remercier
de m'avoir tenta prix
et d'avoir accepté ce jeune président
impétueux
vous les journaux ce qu il est et il
arrive comme ça on part attentes à l'iut
d'annecy où il est urgent aussi devant
les téléphones de ses collègues
étudiants un peu éberlué par ce qu'ils
entendent mon arrivée par fait en
douceur monfils ya quelque chose qu'il
aime bien faire c'est prendre des gros
cailloux et puis petit à petit les poser
les uns par dessus les autres pour
essayer d'empêcher l'autre passé et bien
l'hôpital il en est arrivé au stade où
il ya eu tellement de petits camions qui
se sont succédé chloé ne coule plus
voulu tout et vous nous dites
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient volé
patiemment les cailloux pendant 40 ans
pourquoi est ce que l'eau ne coule plus
mais nous détruisons barrage monsieur
gosselin l'eau allait revenir ça prend
un petit peu de temps oui moi c'était en
gros 20 minutes pour descendre sur que
c'est pas jouable en courant de faits à
800 m de dénivelé
donc donc j'ai décollé et puis je reste
un peu en vol et puis en regardant leur
passé bail à un moment j'ai dit bon
palet comment ai je suis allé poser donc
à limiter monsieur le ministre nous
avait raconté un beau roman une belle
histoire tu pas sûr qu'elles descendent
jusque dans le midi ces timbres
[Musique]
allez on y va